hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by fetch and
yes we are out of abby's kitchen just
temporarily doing a little renovation
but we will be sorting through some of
the
most popular protein powders on the
market
to help you get a better understanding
of protein powders
and which one may suit your lifestyle
first i want to tell you about my
sponsor
fetch so i know that the past year has
been
definitely very challenging one
financially for a lot of us
and i am personally all about finding
little ways
to save wherever i can so fetch rewards
is a super
easy to use free app that lets you
instantly earn rewards on anything you
buy
literally anything amazon purchases
restaurants retail stores you name it
you're not limited to a certain list of
random participating stores
that you never shop at so basically
after you buy
anything you just scan your receipt or
e-receipt on your phone which
literally takes seconds to do and you
earn points
for everything that you buy and then
those points can be saved and redeemed
on things that you
actually want it's not like you get a
free sample of toothpaste or like a food
that you're never gonna eat
you can get the things that you are
already buying for
free like in my case pampers diapers
or ben jerry's hey don't judge and if
you somehow
didn't see something that you needed on
their huge list of brands
you can also get amazon and visa gift
cards with your points as well
so obviously it's really nice to get
good
free stuff that you need just for buying
whatever you're already going to buy so
if you want to try out fetch for
yourself
check out my link in the description and
use my code
abby fetch to get 3 000 points when you
scan your first receipt
now before we get started with this
video feel free to pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating as we will be talking a lot about
macros and calories later on in the
video
so of course feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and of course a quick reminder
to subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a
episode all right folks let's dive in so
i think it's no surprise that protein
powder is one of the
most popular nutrition supplements on
the market
while you can find so many fitness and
nutrition influencers
crediting their gains to their daily
shake the truth is
that there's nothing magical about
protein powder when it comes to building
muscle
or losing weight protein is definitely
very important for both of these things
but protein powder is really just a
really convenient source of it
it's not necessarily superior to food
based sources of protein like
chicken tofu or fish but i do think it
has an important place
and i use it myself personally since
it's just so easy to add a scoop to
a morning smoothie or stir it into your
oats for a balanced snack or meal
having said that it's important to note
that not all
protein powders are created equal and i
get a lot of questions from
all of you on how to choose the right
one
in some cases protein powder might even
be dangerous there have actually been a
few high-profile lawsuits where protein
powders
were called out for containing unlisted
fillers
or inaccuracies in ingredients or
quantities
as i discussed in my nutrition
supplement video right here
supplements including protein powders
are not well regulated by the food and
drug administration or the fda
meaning there's no strict set of rules
or guidelines
about what's in them or how they're
marketed and while the fda
does get involved when there's a
complaint or some kind of
health scare for the most part the onus
is on the manufacturers to
properly evaluate their products and to
be honest in their labeling
and marketing in other words no one's
really
checking their homework this is why
choosing a brand that completes
third-party testing is really important
to me when purchasing
any supplement especially one that is
likely to be consumed
regularly like protein powder
third-party certification
means that an independent organization
has reviewed the manufacturing process
of a product and has independently
determined
that the final product complies with
specific standards for safety
quality or performance generally
speaking
i look at three main places when
choosing a protein powder to evaluate
its safety
and purity labdoor.com nsf
and informed choice labdoor.com is an
awesome website that purchases products
and then sends a sample of each product
to an fda-registered
lab for a detailed chemical analysis
which includes
measurements of active ingredients and
potential contaminants
based on the findings labdor calculates
a quality score
for each product based on label accuracy
product purity nutritional value
ingredient safety
and projected efficacy nsf sport is a
certification program that
lends a stamp of approval to products
that are free of unsafe levels of
contaminants
prohibited substances or masking agents
they also ensure that what's listed on
the label
matches what is in the product finally
informed choice is another company that
verifies the products with their quality
mark
through a four stage certification
process
that basically involves product and
manufacturing reviews
sample testing product certification and
post certification requirements and
testing
if you're unsure about your product that
you use and don't see them listed with
any of these three regulatory bodies you
can always reach out
to the brand directly to ask for their
certification
information and that is exactly what we
did for this video
i asked you on my community page which
brands you were
the most curious about and i did the
research to help you find an option
that has been third party tested and
deemed
safe so let's get into it first of all
let's
talk about my top whey protein options
if you're looking for the best quality
protein in terms of bioavailability
and quality experts agree that whey
protein
is generally your best bet if you try to
whey protein powder in the past and
found that
it caused some gas or bloating you'll
want to look for an
option that uses whey protein isolate or
hydrolyzed whey compared to whey protein
concentrate
which is a cheaper option whey protein
isolate
contains less lactose fat and carbs
and slightly more protein per scoop so
it is ideal for those with
lactose intolerance whey protein
hydrolysate is
pre-digested by enzymes and acids
so it's available to the muscles even
faster and
may also be a little bit easier on the
gut so hydrolyze whey or
whey hydrolysate same thing and weight
isolate
are a little bit more expensive so if
you can tolerate lactose
you might be fine with a basic whey
concentrate formula
based on the brands that you are most
interested in this is what i can
recommend
and just note that the prices were in
usd
and they're based on the website's
current price at the time of filming
which may or may not be currently
accurate
right now so muscle feast is one of the
top rated protein powders on
labdoor.com with a super simple
ingredient list
and 21 grams of grass-fed whey isolate
protein
it's also one of the more affordable
options at just over a dollar per
serving
alani nu is a popular third party tested
option with 23 grams of isolate
and hydrolysate whey they have some
really fun flavors like confetti cake
and munchies but certain flavors do
contain
artificial food colors so just something
to note if you're sensitive to food dyes
like i am then we have my protein impact
weight isolate which is
lab door approved with 19 grams of whey
protein per scoop
and it's available in really fun flavors
like chocolate brownie batter
snickerdoodle and s'mores it's one of
the most affordable options
but it does contain ace k sweetener
which
while safe has been a controversial
sweetener for a while now since
early animal research has linked it to
cancer
that doesn't mean that it causes cancer
of course so don't freak out
but if you personally avoid artificial
sweeteners
you may want to also avoid this brand
now ghost is
nsf certified and packs 25 grams of whey
protein
into each scoop they use a blend of
isolate concentrate and hydrolyze whey
and it's sold in really fun childhood
flavors like nut butter
and chips ahoy they also advertise as
having digestive enzymes which
sound really great but there is
currently no evidence that
enzymes other than lactase aka lactate
and alpha galactosidase aka bino
are at all effective so just note that
that selling feature alone
isn't likely worth the higher price now
garden of life whey isolate is informed
choice and
nsf certified with 24 grams of grass-fed
whey isolate
per scoop plus 2 billion added
probiotics
it is however one of the more pricey
options so
something to definitely keep in mind
ideal fit for women is
also approved via lab door with 20 grams
of whey isolate protein per scoop
they also have some really fun flavors
like fruity cereal
red velvet spiced pumpkin and butter
pecan
and i've tried this one myself and i do
think it is pretty tasty
especially the mint chocolate flavor
i have to tell you i was weary about the
pink tacks with this one since they were
marketing this supplement to
women since newsflash women don't need a
different kind of protein powder than
men do but i actually found that the
prices
were actually quite reasonable and
finally dymatize
iso 100 contains 25 grams of hydrolyzed
isolate whey
with a glowing review on labdoor for its
accuracy
and safety alright so that should give
you lots to chew on
next let's talk about some casein
options so
whey may be the gold standard of protein
powder but there are scenarios where
casein protein is actually preferred
namely as a bedtime snack so casein
protein
is digested and absorbed slower than
whey protein
so it's often used before bed to promote
satiety
and to aid in muscle recovery while you
sleep for this reason
most people prefer casein micellar which
is digested
more slowly than casein hydrolysate or
whey protein when they're mixing up
their bedtime shake
optimum gold standard 100 casein is a
lab door recommended option that we love
because it has 24 grams of micellar
casein per scoop
but it also contains that ace k
sweetener that i mentioned before
and some of the flavors do have high
fructose corn syrup
and gums added so if you're sensitive to
any of that
it's just worth a flag next is a
slightly pricier option called
accent native fuel micellar which is
informed choice certified
with 25 grams of casein protein per
scoop
this one is sweetened with monk
sweetener and stevia if
you're looking for some more natural
sweeteners then we've got
caged muscle casein isolate powder which
is another informed choice pick with
25 grams of micellar casein protein per
scoop
and it's mixed with some coconut creamer
powder
for a really silky texture and of course
i've gotta mention
pez science select so this brand may
sound familiar to you guys if you watch
stephanie bettermore as
it's the base of stephanie's cake pop
oatmeal
but it's unique because it's got 24
grams of a blend of both
whey and casein protein so if you don't
want to have
two different powders for post-workout
and pre-bed
this could be a good option it's also
not only third party tested
but they actually allow you to look up
your container's
lot number online to see all the test
results
finally if you are vegan or dairy free
you'll
obviously want a plant-based option
because casein
and whey protein are both dairy-based
now it's important to note that some
people who have
sensitive guts and maybe are sensitive
to fodmaps
may also find some of the vegan protein
powders a little bit bloating
particularly ones that are made from pea
protein which
most are so just like to keep in mind if
you suffer from ibs
or are super fodmap sensitive now
starting with the most well known
vega sport is vegan and nsf sports
certified with 30 grams of p
and c protein per scoop it also contains
beet powder
and tart cherry powder both of which
have sport based
benefits for performance and recovery
newest
clean lean protein is vegan and third
party tested
with 20 grams of pea protein per scoop
obviously
i dislike the whole clean lean verbiage
and it is one of the most expensive
options on the list
but it does have a very short ingredient
list literally
just three ingredients so if that's a
priority for you
it might be worth the cost now sun
warrior classic
plus is third party tested with 17 to 18
grams of protein per scoop
and they use a unique blend of brown
rice
pea quinoa chia and amaranth the result
is
also rich in vitamin c and plant-based
iron with
a relatively simple ingredient list then
vivo life performed raw plant
protein is highly recommended on
labdor.com
serving up 25 grams of pea and hemp c
protein it's definitely a more expensive
option
at 2.57 cents per serving probably
thanks to the addition of a variety of
superfood powders like maca acai
reishi mushrooms and lucuma fruit the
result however is high in iron
zinc and selenium which not all protein
powders can boast
so if these are lacking in your diet
otherwise
it might be worth the price and finally
four sigmatic is another third-party
tested option
with 18 grams of plant-based protein
from hemp
pumpkin seeds chia peas and coconut it's
also
unique in that they add organic
adaptogenic herbs like ashwagandha
and mushrooms the research for the
former
being a lot more robust than the latter
but honestly
that is a whole video in itself it's
also an
option that's free of added gums and
artificial sweeteners but you're
definitely
paying for all of those bells and
whistles it clocks in
at 3.33 per serving
so this may or may not be worth it to
you i cannot speak to the flavor
but i did try for stigmatics mushroom
coffee which you can watch
right here and let's just say
i wasn't a fan
it doesn't taste like it smells but do
let me know in the comments below if
you've tried this protein powder
and you thought it tasted good now i
also think it's important to mention
some of the companies that
could not confirm that they had been
third party tested
i not only checked the usual websites
for information about their testing
procedures
but our team also reached out to them
personally to see if they could offer
any more details so premium protein said
unfortunately the information that
you're requesting is proprietary
our ingredients are listed on the
packaging in order by weight
heaviest to lightest um okay now
bulk protein said we only do a third
party test
if we don't have an in-house method or
the proper equipment to test the
products
ourselves so to answer your question
that is a no
okay organe's website states
we carefully source our ingredients and
review testing to ensure
products conform to our rigid
specifications for quality
and consistency our products are tested
for arsenic
cadmium mercury and lead so that sounds
good
but they wouldn't answer our emails
regarding third party testing
and their website didn't confirm that
that had been done either
so it's very possible that they are
testing and the products are totally
safe and great however they may not be
third party tested
by an external source and finally
tropica
never answered my email about testing
and i could find
nothing online to confirm that they are
regularly tested
at all you suck so that's not to say
that these brands are
unsafe or even that they're not third
party tested
but i just couldn't obtain hard proof
either way
also it's important to clarify that this
is not an
extensive list and i'm literally
scratching
the surface here i also can't confirm
how all of these
taste since well protein powder is damn
expensive
and i can't exactly order myself a
container of every single one of these
to try
so i do recommend trying to order sample
packs before you
invest in a whole container now if
you're wondering how your protein powder
stacks up
check out labdoor.com and read the
manufacturer's website very carefully
for information on their testing
procedures well folks that is all for
today
thank you again to fetch for sponsoring
this video if you like this video please
be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below about what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye